good morning John I'm here today with
Michael Aranda hello
introduce yourself my name is Michael
Aranda I framed this shot poorly today
Michael and I are going to be putting
together the Millennium Falcon Oh are
they making you to the people first the
people seems like they're the most fun
part you should save that for last mrs.
hunt hair somebody's legs where are all
the heads I'm solo is complete this
thing was not cheap by the way it took
me a couple guesses to guess how much it
cost they forgot to number this bag
thank goodness did he figure that out
cuz I would never have what the rule I
think it was gonna can always think of
that lemon don't like it she doesn't
like it too
I don't know right pieces like make Lego
happen what are these this this is fro
this is still from bag two dozen this
bag one oh look we're gonna use it right
now we are where do you put it
I don't know hold it well you do the
rest in the page 75 no to before is the
other book dude
the two will happen when the two happens
they're pastel what are they taste like
like Reese's Pieces but harder harder
that I don't like them I did this wrong
we're installing tube part which Michael
is very excited about earlier tubular
really yeah
their victim that's page of the first
paw terrible.i I dropped an egg in my
cookie
we're on a number five show them the
Millennium Falcon as it currently exists
ah got it scary we put the feet on we've
got a blaster on the bottom tier your
living facing the heart no it's like
every time you finish a baguette he like
is from harder to easier to easier to
easier to find pieces then you start a
new bag it's like ah hard to get gored
again mad mark again tardigrade italy so
now we're i continue our field
[Music]
it is now 2 o'clock in the morning
Mikael is finished with his Mountain Dew
the Millennium Falcon has another
blaster Amadei actually looks pretty
much like Millennium Falcon right bag
number 6
careful didn't do it so I don't know
what's happening
everyone it's finished
[Music]
John I'll see you on Tuesday